hi there steve here i'm going to do a
second uh video right here uh in seville
uh and i want to talk about language
learning and the brain because i've been
doing a lot of reading on the subject
and i kind of like reading
about the subject i read about it in
english but i also
have read about it in french in german
and portuguese and spanish because
it's an opportunity for me to read about
something that interests me in different
languages
um
i must say that
after a while i find the information
quite contradictory
it seems that every six
all of these books they seem to refer to
some of the same tests with monkeys and
rats and people and
people who had amnesia or
whatever his name was phineas somebody
or other who had a
big spike driven through his head and
and all these different things and they
draw somewhat different conclusions and
they're somewhat different
um
you know research
experiments and so forth
uh it used to be thought that the
language skills were controlled on in
the left side of the brain now the
feeling is that it's controlled on both
sides of the brain
uh some of the people say that we are do
some parts of our language in the broca
area and in some other area and
you know it's kind of contradictory so
you know it's a bit like this whole
business about whether or not eggs are
good for you and whether they have good
cholesterol or bad cholesterol i always
ate eggs never worried about it i just
felt that eggs are healthy
and i think when it comes to trying to
understand
how we learn and how the brain affects
how we learn
you know i think we all have to kind of
draw our own conclusions
and so i'm going to share with you what
some of my conclusions are and this is
not tremendously scientific other than
the fact that i've sifted through a lot
of
books on the subject
i do believe that the brain naturally
learns it learns on its own and it takes
time learning and it learns all the time
and the more stimulus you give it the
better
uh
i was quite interested in a book by a
person's name i can't remember but who
talked about what he called the the
wisdom paradox i think was the name of
the book
and his thing was that the left side of
the brain is where we have
anything that is an established pattern
and that's what we rely on
for most of our learning and most of our
reactions and that the right side of the
brain is where
new ideas new patterns are introduced
now whether in fact it's the right side
the left side or some other combination
of stuff happening the brain doesn't
matter to me but i believe that that's
true that that we establish certain
routines
and and in doing so that becomes
efficient for the brain because we no
longer have to consider all possible
combinations we just
refer to the pattern so we've excluded
say in the case of language
sounds that we didn't hear as a child
grammatical structures that we didn't
hear as a child these are now excluded
we have started to there might have been
a period when we were young
you know in our first few years where
any
pattern any language pattern chinese
french spanish whatever swahili could
have been imprinted on our brain as the
standard reliable
pattern
and so during that period it's open
season but once we
sort of settle on
one pattern then that's the pattern so
now when you want to introduce another
language it's got to come through that
innovative side of the brain
front back left right i don't care
and so i believe that's the case and
then as we get
um enough comfort with this new pattern
it stocks in the place let's call it on
the left side of the brain and now we
rely on that so now we're able to do
things more you know
unself-consciously that's one thing i
believe i also believe
that the right side of the brain
or the innovative side of the brain
is always looking in order for these
things to become a pattern
is looking for associations comparisons
to things that are already in place in
the brain
and therefore
learning
words and meaning and phrases
uh is a lot easier than learning
a theoretical structure
because for example when i go to study
russian the theoretical explanation of
russian
uh with all the rules and and exceptions
so i i i can't deal with it i've never i
have nothing to refer to but if you tell
me that in russian the word for horse is
this and the word for cow is that
i can understand that and if you say
uh
you know that people say
what is your name in this way and it's
not translated as what is your name name
uh
then okay that equates to that so i can
understand that so that learning based
on meaning to my mind is more effective
and i i mean we see it all the time uh
people with with with very large
vocabularies in english still get the
third person singular wrong it's not a
difficult concept it's the only
uh form of the verb that changes we put
an s on there he goes i go hugo i go
tomorrow whatever he went we went we
went none of those change but the third
person singular changes
simple
all kinds of people can't do it because
you've got to change a pattern in that
left side or whatever side of the brain
it is that controls these comfortable
patterns that you have so meaning
is going to be the way to bring the
language in i believe
i also believe that we need to be
attentive and we need to help our brain
to notice
and i have noticed that myself that all
kinds of things fly by me that i don't
notice until i get them wrong two or
three times or i just happen to be
listening and i hear something oh yeah
that's what they do and so then maybe
you notice it a few more times and
gradually then it moves from the
novelty innovative side to the
you know
pattern side so
you know in all of this about how the
brain learns those are the things that i
think are important we can we the other
thing i do believe is that we learn both
when we are consciously learning but
also when we are not consciously
learning and i've had this a number of
times like in my russian learning
i all of a sudden i have all these texts
unlinked that are just covered
in in yellow highlighted words those are
words that i once looked up i know them
all
i haven't necessarily flash carded them
all but i know them all
and there's a bunch of words that i'm
adding to my new word total that i never
even looked up
so that we are learning stuff
almost implicitly
and i have also observed that if i stop
my russian for a couple of months or a
month when i go back to it i've actually
improved so there's a gestation that
goes on in the brain
so the brain does a lot of learning on
its own but on the other hand the brain
is not like
an animal that you domesticate and tame
and you know you give them a little
cookie and the the dog gives you its
hand
yeah the brain likes to be rewarded it
likes to get that sense of
satisfaction but it won't act on command
and it won't learn things on command and
you can't deliberately study the
declension table and then expect that
you're going to know it you won't so the
brain
does respond to reward it does respond
to a sense of achievement the brain
likes new things stimulates it
but it doesn't necessarily act on
command
the other thing that i think is very
important about the brain and language
learning in particular is that
as we get older we of course we rely
more and more on the sort of established
patterns we have and this is something
that
in this book on the paradox of wisdom
and the wisdom paradox is pointed out
that that we become more efficient we
have this wisdom we have such a
tremendous range of accumulated patterns
that we can more easily make decisions
we know how to deal with situations
because we've seen them before
so that's a positive side on the
negative side we may become less open to
new ideas and new languages and
therefore i think that it's very good
for the brain and it tends to keep the
brain younger
and rejuvenate the brain to learn
another language i think it's a
tremendously
uh positive thing to do to stimulate the
brain in this way and we know that the
brain remains plastic throughout our
lives even though
the brain does go through certain
changes presumably so learning another
language to keep that innovative side of
your brain if we follow the
the wisdom paradox example to keep that
going stimulating forcing you to bring
new
patterns
into the sort of pattern side of your
brain keeps the brain young
so
that's my take and all of this very
often
contradictory information
and i like having my view of how my
brain works
i don't know how my car works i don't
know how the cholesterol in eggs affects
my cholesterol but i drive my car and i
eat eggs and i learn languages
based on this very rough and
unscientific superficial
summary of my reading to date on the
subject i am expected to get roundly
criticized by people much more
knowledgeable than i am on the subject
thank you for listening